what are the biggest do's and don'ts for
me while I'm in New York I will say it's
all ticked up the craziness is ticked up
since the pandemic because the hobos ran
the city we all went indoors so they
just were running rampant and now the
city's back and they're still there so
there's a real Clash of normies and hobo
I would just say don't do the Subway
after midnight it gets cold and they go
down there and that's where the real
action happens that's like slashings and
uh shootings and whatnot so what do you
do if you have to go just I hope for the
best yeah I got mugged uh once on the
subway and that was my fault actually I
was at your fault I drank too much back
then I was blacked out I fell asleep on
the train I woke up to a guy on his
knees doing the exacto knife around the
pockets and I was like I stood up and I
hit my head on the pole and I fell back
down and kind of like knocked myself out
he was so nonchalant like don't worry
the train will turn it back around hang
on the guy that moved to you made you
feel comforted that you messed your stop
he was Charming